we're all good to go chad i think lovely
thank you uh good afternoon my name is
councillor mcpherson and i am the
chairman of the licensing and appeals
subcommittee
the other members are
and if uh uh councillor mrs lorraine
shaw if you could indicate
hello i'm councillor shaw from rdc thank
you
thank you and councillor mrs dewport
councillor lisa newport from spain park
and grange ward thank you um and the
committee's legal advisor is mr chris
irwin before we start connecting man
present that
everyone present make sure they have
switched off their mobile phones the
purpose of today's hearing
is to hear an application for premises
license made by 21st century licensing
on behalf of the applicant kraftwerk
beers limited in respect of the premises
known as craftwork the former public
conveniences crown hill rayleigh essex
ss6 7 hy
please could the applicant and
representatives in introduce themselves
if you could um thank you
good afternoon chair good afternoon
officers
my name is paul richards i'm
representing 21st century licensing as a
licensing consultant on behalf of my
client
good afternoon my name is stephen
reynolds
i'm the owner of kraftwerk beers and i'm
the interesting party taking over that
building
thank you and uh do you have any
witnesses you would like to call today
uh we don't care
thank you
uh please go to council's licensing
office to introduce themselves
uh hello i'm karis brooke i'm the
licensing officer at rochford district
council
thank you and do you have any witnesses
you'd like to call today no
thank you
have all part parties receive the agenda
and report for today's hearing if you
could indicate
yeah i can see everybody
uh nodding thank you chairman i think
you just need to check the um interested
parties just to see i think there's a
couple of people on the call just to
introduce themselves as well uh um i do
apologize um i have only got the
screen with um as many people and that
allows um
so could
let me just go back
please could the interested parties
present introduce themselves so again
members of the public who are present if
you could unmute and introduce
yourselves
hi um my name's russell brown i'm a
resident on crown hill
thank you very much mr brown and have
you got any witnesses you'd like to call
today
no no
thank you
can we just ask the interested party if
they're able to put their camera on as
well i think it's just better for the
i can switch to another one if that's
but it doesn't work very well so
i think that's fine in the circumstance
unless you have a different view
um i don't have a problem fellow members
no thank you
okay um
so um
everybody else indicated mr brown have
you received also received um all the
papers for today yes i have yes
lovely thank you uh the committee will
now follow the procedure as set out on
the uh procedural note
agenda item number three
please could all parties be reminded
that they each have up to 15 minutes
only to present their case
please good mr
uh sorry miss brook summarize the
application thank you
yes so this report introduces an
application for the grant of a premise
license made under section 17 of the
licensing act 2003.
the application was submitted to the
licensing authority by the 21st century
licensing on behalf of the applicant
craft worked craft work be is limited
and refers to the premises to be known
as craftwork the formal public
conveniences crownhill rayleigh
the premises to which the applicant
relates comprises of the former public
conveniences with the intention to
operate as a micro pub and craft beer
vendor
the premises is located on crown hill
between railey high street and station
road
the application is for the following
licensable activities with the times and
days
uh the activity is the supply of alcohol
both on and off sales for sunday to
thursday 12 pm to 11 p.m and friday to
saturday 12 p.m to 12 a.m
and there's also late night refreshment
from friday to saturday at 11 p.m till
12 a.m and the provision of recorded
music from friday to saturday 12 p.m to
sorry 11 p.m to 12 a.m
the application has been assessed by
both essex police and the council's
environmental health service
both have agreed conditions with the
applicant and they can be seen in
appendix c
we have received eight representations
and six were from local residents and
two from local councillors the
representations raised concerns in
relation to the following licensing
objectives which was the prevention of
public nuisance and public safety
a copy of the representations received
is in appendix d
um it is proposed that the subcommittee
resolves the application to be
determined according to one of the
following options
so either to grant the application
subject to such conditions as are
consistent with the operating schedule
modified to such extent as members
consider necessary for the promotion of
the licensing objectives and any
mandatory condition that must be
included
or to exclude from the scope of the
license any of the licensable activities
to which the application relates
or to reject the application
or
uh subject to paragraphs 1 11 to 13 of
the licensing act 2003 hearings
regulation 2005 to adjourn the hearing
to a specified date or arrange a hearing
to be held on special specified
additional dates where members consider
this to be necessary for their
consideration of any representations or
notices made by a party
that concludes the report
thank you very much
thank you
we now go to members um if you would
like to ask any questions um
counselor mrs lorene shaw would you like
to go first first if you've got any
questions for the licensing officer
sorry german i was muted no i haven't
any for the um licensing officer thank
you
uh councillor mrs newport
no questions for the licensing officer
thank you
thank you um i believe um if officers
can confirm
um our member of the public is allowed
to ask a question
chair um if permitted and for
clarification purposes only but i
wouldn't imagine there'd be anything at
this stage okay
i haven't got any questions yet there
you go thank you
and um our um applicant
have they got any questions of the
licensing officer
we have no questions yeah
thank you um i have um just one question
um perhaps licensed and officer can
advice um is um pub watch still in place
yes
wonderful um is there still the um
provision i think it's called bob
banned from one band from all yeah
they're still in place within the pub
watch
wonderful thank you very much
um we now move and i just need to refer
to my agenda for
next is um
to the applicant
please if you you have now have 15
minutes
um thank you chair um
good afternoon everybody
um first of all i'll send you over to my
client who just wants to tell you a bit
about yourself and uh
with the application
thank you and just before you proceed i
don't know if anybody else is having
problems you sound quite quiet
um yeah other members are not in
is this any better i can speak louder
yeah that's much better thank you very
much okay thank you
uh hello my name's steven reynolds um
and i'm applying to take over the former
public toilets in raleigh and turn them
into a little craft beer bar
um
about myself i come from rayleigh i come
from
uh i went to school and fits well mark
and
i have made i managed the paul pryor for
a small time in raleigh high street and
uh
i've been managing pubs for a decade now
then me and my wife and um craft work in
south end and it's done really well but
always wanted to open one in raleigh
because that's kind of my hometown
that's still where my family comes from
[Music]
we're
trying to
make a um just a kind of nice
safe haven really that's what um the one
in south end's become it's aimed at a
more mature and affluent
um clientele
um
and that's i don't know
what else
so we're here today to determine the
application for
craft worksphere in the former public
convenience in crownhill
as my client said um
his wealth of experience
in london in rayleigh
and currently in south end
the premises that he currently of um
operates in south end is called
craftworks
he's been here three years
and he's there's never been any issues
since him coming in
the licensing authority
has carried out visits and he's always
been compliant
he's been engaging
um
during the
hovid
pandemic
he was fully compliant with all the
regulations that he needed to do
to the satisfaction of the licensing and
environment and health
we
have submitted this application
on his behalf
to
convert the former public convenience at
crown hill
to a
a craft beers
as my client said is currently his his
customers patrons
are of a mature
affluent type who endures
a
a nice beer and a quiet glass of wine
and prosecco
since submitting the application
the police authority environmental
health
added a number of further conditions
which
the licensing officer
stated which is on um appendix d
which would further
assist my client to
um
promote the look for licensing
objectives
along with the
conditions that was attached to the
license
the police have
has
emailed and agreed those conditions
and the environmental health in relation
to noise and they feel confident that
the conditions offered up in the greed
will help to to
negate
any any noise issues
as i said my client has been
in the south end location for the last
three years
the premises is on a a busy street
but there are residential premises above
the commercial premises
and there's not been any
any complaints or reports about noise or
any misconduct
or any mismanagement of the premises
my client is a
local lad from raleigh and he's fully
aware
of the of the
the former
um convenience and he he relishes the
opportunity to convert that
disused building into a nice place where
you sit down and have some have some
alcohol
beverages
and to partake in some cotton cult food
with the application we submitted some
plans
and with the plans the plans are
on page 4.25 of the report
which shows that he'll be removing some
of the foliage
paving the area to have tables and
chairs outside which will allow his
patrons to sit down and enjoy the
ambulance of the premises and
surrounding areas
there has been a number of them
objections and majority of the
objections are
they mainly
concerned about customers spilling out
onto the pavement
now
a lot of these
objections came in possibly before they
had the opportunity to actually look at
the plans that was submitted with the
application
as you can see on the plans on page 4.25
[Music]
the area will be removed to college and
and walls and tables and chairs
which would be
aesthetically pleasing to the building
which will allow patients to remain on
the premises
and partake in non-vertical drinking
and have some hot and cold food that
will be supplied from the premises
the noise impact
again the
um
i am
i'm not saying that there isn't an issue
or possibility of issues of noise
from
regulus
but they are
not from my client's premises as he's
not started there
his
his clientele
is as they said is a mature
affluent
um audience which is 30s a plus
it won't be attracting the the young
teenagers
the the beers and the beers that will be
on sale are craft beers which are not
properly obtained
um
the pricing of that they will start at
around six pounds
so it's not
like the
i won't name any bears but
certain beers at a lower end
of the market which are
purchased and
and sold cheaply and in abundance
these are
good crafted award-winning beers
um
that he will be bringing to the premises
very much in line what he offers
here at the craftworks in southie
again
he's looking to replicate his success
of the current locations in southend
um
and continue
a
long trouble-free establishment
where people will have an alternative to
go where they don't want to drink a pint
of beer watching the football and
partaking in in
loud singing
it's
a nice quiet environment there will be
no loud
live music
it will be all background music
recorded
and just played to help the ambience of
of the premises and the environment
the music will not be heard beyond the
boundaries of the footprint of the
premises
and my client will regularly be
patrolling those boundaries and ensuring
that not only the music
cannot be heard from those boundaries
but also his patrons are not outside of
these boundaries partaking in
in any form of anti-social behavior
my client here now
he engages with the residents
he wishes and does currently operate
alongside other commercial premises
and along with residents
and he welcomes residents to come into
him
majority of them are his customers and
they pop into a quick drink say hello
and then
move on
you engage
and he'll make any adaptions within
reason that will help negate any
problems or any concerns
my client is a professional hardworking
[Music]
publican
who has run several establishes um
not only in essex but
in london and the home counties
and
he's
he submitted this application to take
over this used building
which is is 90 years old and he wishes
to
allow the building to continue being
used
possibly for another 90 years
it is an important building
everybody in the area
is aware of this building because it's
an icon
and as my client says
he wishes
if the license is granted
he will be working hard to actually make
that premises a crown in history
now
um
as i say there could well be and i'm not
denying it from from the recommendations
that there are noises
many of the the
objections have stated that
the current premises
in the area
will discard their bottles late into the
night
but as you can see
the conditions that were agreed with the
police
to combat noise and disorder
and with the environmental health to
combat the public nuisance
you can clearly see that condition one
to nine clearly deals with public
nuisance
and they are
from
not disposing your waste
after nine o'clock
not using the outside um sorry
so
um
yeah the the doors and windows of the
premises sorry should be closed
at nine o'clock
however there will be people still in
the grounds and the music will be even
lowered so it will not be heard
my client again would patrol and ensure
that his clienteles are not beyond the
perimeters of the building or of the
land
and they will not be standing
vertically drinking industry
this is not something this is something
that discourages his current premises
and he has discouraged in many other
establishments that he has run and and
managed
along with the conditions that was
agreed with the the responsible
authorities
there was a number of conditions
attached to the
attached to the application
and i truly believe that with these
conditions and all these conditions
with the experience of my my client
[Music]
he has the ability if the license is
granted to make a success of this this
premises and actually be a positive
uh premises which will engage with the
residents and
hopefully the said residents who are
objecting now will become
customers of the
of the premises
sorry sorry to interrupt um chair we've
lost um council newport so we're just
waiting for
her to be reconnected if we could just
um
pause with the evidence for a second
oh your muted chair
sorry about that um
if we can just pause then and wait for
councillor mrs newport to join us i
believe um
uh
mr
um reynolds and mr richards you've got
two minutes left okay
chair just to clarify for other people
not who didn't know that i when i look
at why i'm actually looking at the
agenda on a different screen so i'm not
looking okay thank you i think we've all
got that
problem excitedness